peut être un jour un étranger demande à
nice l'aude
donnez moi une bonne raison de venir en
islande en niveau l'islandais répondu
nous sommes 250 milles mais en hiver
nous sommes le doubs pourquoi 1 parce qu
en hiver tous les spectres compte le
pays alors je viens tout de suite
complète
[Applaudissements]
tous les
rekem à 2500 km à peine au nord de paris
la petite capitale 125 mille habitants
d'une île sans arbres lisselan reykjavik
la ville aux maisons blanches et au toit
coloré calme comme une ville de province
ces premiers habitants se serait appelé
les vikings
[Musique]
donc
mais
[Musique]
en islande raconté se dit sa gamme et
sur le port de reykjavik les fleisher
parle encore de cette histoire d'amour
qui coûta la vie à une art le fermer
encerclé par ses ennemis
une arme avec son arc pour se défendre
mais la corde cède il demanda alors à sa
femme algarve dure un mois de mai de tes
cheveux et tresses les lives and ma vie
ordinaire souviens toi du jour lointain
où tu m'a giflé les pêcheurs disent qu
elles guerre durera longtemps nous le
dit répétant sans cesse
j'ai donné la mort à celui que j'aimais
le plus au reste place ça y est comparé
à 14h30 à coller à courir i7 au nord de
l'île là au 19e siècle
un condamné à mort pouvait sauver sa
tête s'il acceptait de s'enfoncer à
l'intérieur des terres vivantes ainsi
seuls loin de ces crimes
ce matin la tempête rendait encore le
nord inaccessible elle avait recouvert
d'une épaisse couche de neige
les 350 km de cailloux qui sépare
reykjavik d'akureyri
m
ouais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les enfants fait le saut
râble la coutume voulait ce jour là
qu'on enferme un chat dans un tonneau
rempli de friandises les enfants taper
sur le tonneau et à la mort du chat ils
se précipitaient sur les bonbons
beaucoup
il appellera pas sonné chez
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
la route numéro un fait le tour de l
route autre assez étrange sinueux au
moment de sa construction
les ingénieurs ont dû s'incliner sous la
pression les habitants qui refusaient le
passage à certains endroits hantée
disait-il par les elfes et les trolls
elle mène au lac nivan à 80km d'akureyri
avant de plonger vers les grands fjord
de l'est
[Musique]
soudain le blanc sans alliés pour
trouver la route un homme doit courir
devant la voiture dans cet univers on
croise parfois des apparitions
vous êtes sur le bon chemin
le lac n'est plus très loin le facteur
fait sa tournée
il sait que le camion du laitier va
passer suivez le dit il
sur la route aveugle le laitier roulent
à plus de 60 km comme si les elfes le
guide et voilà le lac myvatn est là
devant invisible pour l'instant mais
comme dit le proverbe étrangers si tu
n'aimes pas ce temps patiente une minute
[Musique]
à
un jour dieu va trouver adam et eve et
demandent à avoir leurs enfants
mais f dissimule à ce qu'elle n'avait
pas eu le temps de n'avait d'yeux qui le
savaient y ce qui doit mettre cachet
sera caché aux c'est ainsi que ses
enfants de martin visite ce sont les
ailes avec les trolls et géant
ils habitent les montez les auteurs les
pierres et les trous les humains ne
peuvent jamais voir les elfes à moins
que ceux-ci le veut
non
bravo
autour du lac divatte le rock et la
glace la lave et le feu ici les légendes
se raconte au présent
c'est la cour l'inde pour des centrales
en fait et ça vous fait penser à dante
et 9 une vernon là sur cette montagne
seul refuge qui est brûlé toute cette
mentale et est ensuite et au chant de là
ça fait penser peut-être à pour nos
propres toiles
et avec ce film qui est chanté dans la
pierre mais en plein hiver dans la piège
mais mais mais bush avait demandé si je
suis réaliste
mais quand on revient dans le camp par
le snes dans le péché ma maturité et
j'entendais la rumeur d'une fleur est
tout de suite où j'entendais le voir qui
vous parle
[Musique]
partout connaissons
l'hiver durera jusqu'en mai les gens
d'ici ne sortent que par nécessité
ils ont le temps on leur maison le temps
de raconter comme le pasteur du village
[Musique]
il y à un endroit derrière la mort
réalisé il ne faut pas l'appeler c'est
la demeure de la fée york brown et si
l'on coupe l'herbe elle se vengera alors
personne n'ose toucher l'herbe à cet
endroit
[Musique]
où
dans les fermes les paysans bloqués par
la neige parle du sort de la jeune a
guère dur qui vous vous souvenez donna
la mort agnar qu'elle aimait tant
combattre la cuisine cours on me demande
souvent ce qu'est devenue cette femme
qui n'avait pas voulu donner ses cheveux
[Musique]
après la mort de gunnar dont on dit
qu'elle a erré un temps dans le pays
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle a disparu
pourtant vous savez c'est rare dans une
saga de ne pas connaître la destinée des
personnages loufoques et m
c'est important
moi le contact avec la nature et les
légendes et tout le monde est
intéressant portant à l'inter du fière
de nous et je pense que peut-être nous
nous sombrerons pas achevé que nous
sommes comme les japonais un peu
schizophrène
je
le lagon bleu un lac d'eau chaudes
venues des profondeurs de la terre
lou l'une des richesses de l'islande
l'hiver elle réchauffe les maisons et
les corps qu'en dehors il fait moins 10
degrés
avant de partir l'étranger demanda alors
à l'islande est vous qui vivez au milieu
des elfes donnez moi une bonne raison de
vous quitter
[Musique]